-Our next guest
is an Oscar-nominated
and Golden Globe and
Emmy Award-winning actress
you know from over 50 films,
including such classics
as "Bye Bye Birdie,"
"Carnal Knowledge,"
and "Viva Las Vegas."
She stars in "Queen Bees,"
which is in theaters
and on demand now.
Let's take a look.
-Are you flirting with that gu
with the squirrel on his head?
-Esther said
he's a wonderful lover.
-Oh, and here comes my lunch
-I bet he takes Viagra.
-Mm.
-From the looks on the faces
of the ladies,
he's buying it by the truckload.
[ Laughs ]
-Please welcome to the sho
Ann-Margret!
Ann-Margret, I am thrilled
you are here.
-[ Laughing ]
I'm just laughing at that scene.
Ah. How you doing?
-I'm doing well.
-Nice to meet you.
-It is so nice to meet you
as well.
We have very little in common,
but we do have one thing,
which is we both went
to Northwestern University
But you had a very --
a very short time there
because you were discovered...
in your first year there?
-Oh, let's see.
No. I went one whole year.
And then a group that I was with
from Northwestern
called the Suttletones --
took us three hours
to get that name --
at The Hut.
Is it still there, The Hut
-I don't think The Hut
is still there, no.
-[ Laughs ] Oh, no.
Oh, how embarrassing.
Okay.
Mr. Burns --
I auditioned for him.
And everything really starte
from there,
'cause he took me in his sho
in Las Vegas
at the Sahara hotel.
Everything started from there.
I loved it.
-And early in your career,
you worked with people,
you know, like Elvis Presley
Steve McQueen.
Are your memories of those
still vivid?
Does that feel like
a completely other time?
-Oh, no, no, no.
I remember that.
I remember everything workin
with those two gentlemen.
Also, with McQueen,
I love motorcycles,
and, of course,
he loved motorcycles.
And the studio was giving me
a lot of trouble
because I was very young
and they were --
and I drove it to the studio
and they got very nervous an
did not want me to drive it.
And so McQueen just said,
"Oh, forget about it.
That's their job.
They have to be nervous
about something."
So I kept driving it.
-[ Laughs ]
At what point in your life
did you stop riding motorcycles?
-I have not stopped.
-[ Laughs ] I'm very, very
happy to hear that.
You know, this is
a little embarrassing
because now I'm very familia
with your career,
but it dawned on me today
that the first time
I think I heard your voice
was when you played
the "Flintstones" characte
Ann-Margrock.
Do you remember that?
-Yes, with Pebbles.
-[ Laughs ] It was...
You guys were wonderful
together.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you. I'll tell her.
-So, this show --
sorry, this film --
has sort of been described
as "Mean Girls"
in a retirement home,
but it's also very sweet.
We saw in the clip we showed
the very funny people
you are working with --
Jane Curtin, Christopher Lloyd
You also work with Ellen Burstyn
in this film.
This is actually
your third film together.
But is it true that
it's the first time
you've ever done
a scene together?
-The very first time.
Because I always...
In the other two films,
I played the other woman,
so we didn't have
any scenes together.
-There's something during th
pandemic that you've maintained,
which is --
-[ Vocalizing ]
-[ Laughs ]
You've maintained a traditio
during the pandemic
which I think is very nice
for people.
So many of us did not get to
have enough human interaction.
You do a Friday dinner
with the same pair of friends.
-Yes! Oh, yes.
It's one of my former dancers,
Tommy Peel,
and his partner, Denny Dugan
After my husband, Roger,
passed away --
it's now been four years -
Tommy said to me,
"I want you to come over
for dinner every Friday night.
So it's been that way
for four years.
And, see, I don't cook,
and I don't care.
[ Laughing ]
So the only way I can --
No. It's been so wonderful
It's great.
-Are there any parts
of your career,
anything you look back --
'Cause it's been such a storie
and accomplished career.
Anything you wish you coul
go back and relive?
-No. I want to just remember i
the way it was.
'Cause, like,
with movies and everything
I did the very best I coul
in whatever movie it was
and I don't want
to revisit that.
-'Cause it's true, you don't g
back and watch your work.
Is that correct?
-No, I can't sit
and gaze at myself.
[ Laughing ] No.
No, no, no, no. No.
I put everything I have
into whatever film I'm doing
So that's it.
-Well, we appreciate
that you do and that you did
And I can tell you,
from where I'm sitting,
it's very easy to gaze
at yourself,
and I've enjoyed it
for a very long time.
And thank you for making tim
for us today, Ann-Margret.
-Oh, what a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
-"Queen Bees" is in theaters
and on demand now.